the dark doesn't look very good these
days and I'm really sorry if you are one
of the lucky ones who's never noticed
this because now I'll point it out now I
artificially increase the brightness on
the dark parts in this video so you can
see what the shadows behind me actually
looked like now you'll notice in movie
trailers in dark scenes and even
prestige television in YouTube videos
weather nice calm gradient backgrounds
you see this dreadful color banding
there are three reasons for it and the
first is that there aren't enough colors
alright I'll turn the lights on in most
modern digital video there's a grand
total of about sixteen point seven
million possible colors and that number
comes from how your screen works when
you watch a video your phone computer or
TV takes that compressed digital signal
that's being sent to you and it converts
it into instructions those instructions
go to the screen which changes the
brightness of each of the millions of
red green and blue lights that make up
your screen up to sixty times a second
perfectly it's incredible technology
that we just take for granted but those
little lights can't be adjusted to any
drunkness the simplest digital signal
would just tell the screen whether to
turn each light on or off each
instruction would take a single bit a
single one or zero so for each pixel
each combination of red green and blue
that gives you eight possible colors 2
times 2 times 2 which doesn't look great
so ok let's add another bit for each
color two-bits gives us 4 options for
each light off dark sorta bright and
completely on now we've got 4 times 4
times 4 64 colors it still doesn't look
great for a modern screen you need 8
bits for each pixel so you've got 256
shades each of red green and blue which
gives you those 16 million colors that
you used too and that ought to be enough
right it seemed to be when the standards
were written and to be fair every bit
you add means more dates to transmit and
more expensive equipment it seemed like
a pretty good compromise at the time
professionals like people working in
digital cinema they go further they
might use 10 bits for each pixel giving
them about a billion total possible
colors instead and you may well have a
fancy screen that can show those more
nice billion colors but the picture
quality is determined by the weakest
link in the chain a ludicrously
expensive HDR monitor isn't going to fix
the color banding on that regular
YouTube video anyway it was decided that
256 shades each red green and blue
combined however you like that should be
enough amongst people and for almost
everything it is but at full resolution
this video is 1920 pixels wide and there
are only 256 shades of green so if I
have a green gradient across the whole
video views every shade of pure green
that is possible on this format then
you're still gonna have a color band
every 7 or 8 pixels and if everything is
much darker than that well suddenly you
might only have half a dozen different
shades of green available across the
whole picture even if you're using a bit
of red and blue in there as well there
just aren't that many available dark
colors but you've got a plains bright
background why doesn't that have color
banding all over it well the second
reason is how human eyesight works there
is color banding all over this video
right now if we take a sample of the
bright gradient behind me and massively
increase the contrast you can see it's
there but normally it's invisible and
that's because while the absolute
difference between two bands is still
the same the relative difference is tiny
it's the same reason that this chart
looks a lot closer than this chart going
from 201 to 202 feels like a tiny change
but going from 1 to 2 is a doubling even
in both cases the absolute changes the
same one we perceive one as being bigger
than the other but even if you don't
have enough colors you can break up
gradients another way you can use
dithering instead of going from one
color to another at a line you can
steadily transition from one to the
other you can make the boundary fuzzy so
that from a distance the colors appear
to blend and if you film your real life
scene we'll that'll happen in camera the
natural light and the noise in the
signal and the sensor will do that for
you it actually works really well it
more or less solves the problem but it
won't look like that here and that
brings me to the third reason
compression of raw HD video uncompressed
means somewhere around a gigabit per
second of data even if you have an
internet connection that can somehow
support streaming all that it's
incredibly wasteful and X
to use all that data so every streaming
service YouTube Netflix everyone uses
lossy compression a program called an
encoder takes a massive high-quality
video file and then throws away fine
detail to save data the more the video
is compressed the worse it looks but
it'll work on slower and slower
connections and it'll be cheaper and
cheaper to run your streaming service
but at some point the viewers are gonna
notice that the picture doesn't look
great but the encoder the compression
software is written by very clever
people and it works out which bits of
the scene the viewer is probably going
to be interested in and put some most of
its effort into making that part look
good and that's usually a bright sharp
part of the scene something
well-lit and in focus and probably the
bits that are moving now there are
exceptions when there's some slow
menacing threat out of focus in the
background but for almost every scene if
it's dark or out of focus
chances are the director and the viewer
doesn't care about it so the encoder
doesn't care about it either if they're
only 50 kilobits fifty thousand ones and
zeros available to describe each frame
of video then the encoder will make sure
that most of those are spent where the
viewers likely to be looking all that
dithering all the fancy stuff in the
background too expensive smear it out
into just big blocks of solid color
nominal notice and we won't unless it's
also very dark at which point there will
be something nasty look
you